[Musique]
qui
avec pièce bonjour merci d'être sur le
plateau de tv 78 d'odeurs par la neige
oui oui ce temps hivernal vous êtes
gentiment venu ici en voisin vous étiez
3 4 ou êtes yvelinois je n'habitais pas
trop loin heureusement vous êtes
chercheur à l'inra vous travaillez à
l'agroparistech dans le 5e et vous êtes
spécialisé en physique chimie
gastronomie moléculaire en gastronomie
la discipline il s'agit de c'est pas de
la cuisine
il s'agit de chercher les mécanismes des
phénomènes en gros si un souffle et
gonfle pourquoi ce qui gonfle si une
viande s'attendrit quand la cuy pourquoi
le ska le cendrier alors voilà ça c'est
le début puis après on part le début
justement le grand public vous connaît
justement par vos travaux sur la
gastronomie moléculaire comme vous dites
comment on peut définir cette cette
pratique en quelques années c'est pas
une pratique enfin ces disciplines
scientifiques la discipline scientifique
gastronomie moléculaire c'est chercher
les mécanismes des phénomènes qui
surviennent quand on cuisine
voilà dix ans mais en fait ça il ya eu
en même temps c'est là où il ya de la
confusion s'est en même temps j'avais
inventé la cuisine moléculaire
voilà en 1981 et la cuisine moléculaire
ça veut dire cuisiner de façon
raisonnable enfin moderne
au lieu d'avoir des fouets des
casseroles comme au moyen-age on a des
siphons des ampoules à décanter des
épices et aujourd'hui elle est partout
elle est partout dans le monde entier
dans tous les cas ce que vous voyez la
cuisson basse température seigneur
résultat la cuisine moléculaire
ah c'est vous qui avez trouvé je disais
aux gens il trône et prenait de ces
objets qu'on en laboratoire pour cuire
précisément et ils sont équipés
progressivement après fair and adria et
des chefs comme ça et elodie a partout
vous allez chez dans un grand magasin
acheter un four il ya une fonction basse
température
donc c'est par tous ces gars ça il faut
passer à la suite je vous exhorte donc
là c'était pour la moine est clair alors
la suite vous m'aviez dit quand on
s'était vus il ya quelques années
pour un vie pareille vous m'aviez parlé
la cuisine note à note
alors ça c'est signé la suite on est
d'accord c'est la suite leurs lacunes
notées note c'est exactement comme ces
deux là c'est de la cuisine de synthèse
on va dire voilà alors pour pour ce pour
faciliter l'idée c'est lié dans le temps
en jouant de la musique avec des
violents des trompettes et plus encore
et à l'époque ont cuisiné avec des
légumes des viandes et des poissons
il ya cent ans on a commencé à analyser
les son ski tout toute l'électronique
l'actuel s'est fondée là dessus les bio
au même moment qu'elle a commencé à
analyser les aliments donc on a vu
qu'une carotte c'est de l'eau de la
cellulose du glucose du fructose du
saccharose du baht a carotène traitement
il ya cinquante ans on
il fallait une pièce d'ordinateurs pour
faire la musique de synthèse mais
aujourd'hui c'est 22 euros synthétiseur
dans un magasin de jouets et vous avez
vu que j'ai pas parlé de ce côté là de
la cuisine il se passe exactement la
même chose
là je vous ai apporté par exemple ici du
cd des polyphénols de chira de faugères
2012 donc ça c'est point pas d'enjeu
coupe c'est pour nous expliquer la
claque de la note assez la ville aux
notes vous prenez des composés de l'au
delà c'est pas un truc fait maison du
vin et on va dès qu'on prouve à saray
les composés oui enfin on les a déjà
vous avez déjà vous avez de l'eau vous
avez de la cellulose avait des graisses
vous avez du gluten vous avez du lactose
ça se trouve déjà partout celui-là suis
là c'en est un alors voyez c'est qu'est
ce que c'est que cela c'est des
polyphénols ces polyphénols ces dessins
vous servir du vin cela c'est un
constituant du vin ouais c'est une
poudre
rouge parce que c'est avait passé du
raisin de ciral au syrah cépage rouge et
vous en prenez 1/4 de cuillère et avec
avec deux verdu il avait une sauce ouais
comme une chance en vain après vous
pouvez améliorer pour faire bon vous
mettez un peu d'acide tartrique vous
mettez de la star trek c'est très très
bon moi je mets sur la table à l'horizon
g sel poivre
c'est arte rectrice blague non non non
parce que d'habitude j'ai mis un petit
petit peu d'acidité dans les plats oui
la cuisine et faut pas qu'elle tombe
dans le gras ou qu'elle tombe dans le
sucre faut à tout prix payés y est une
tare triaire d'acide tartrique c'est
super rien mais ça remplace quoi la
sinne
ça donne de l'acidité par exemple ah oui
bien sûr mais si vous voulez chiffre
comprenait de l'acide citrique rené kuhn
soufrière et ouais ce que je vais
trouver ça on chez les pâtissiers les
boulangers pâtissiers il utilisera les
eurobonds oui mais d'ailleurs l'oeuf en
poudre très intéressant allez voir
pourquoi avoir des oeufs qui s'allument
kick ass
alors que vous auriez un bocal moi j'ai
ça la maison de la poudre de blanc
d'oeuf vous en prenez 3 g avec un peu
d'eau ou refaites un bluff et vous le
battez en neige pareil et pourquoi avoir
on n'est plus au moyen-âge et donc la
cuisine de demain ça sera une très belle
armoire voyez comme les trucs de
pharmaciens en bois anciens et des jolis
pots dedans et des et avec ça on fera la
cuisine ça va être super et peut-être
des imprimantes 3d parce qu'avec une
imprimante 3d vous mettez ces produits
et vous sortez un plat qui peut avoir
une forme de pyramide creuse avec dans
une sphère des différentes couleurs
ça veut dire coeur à cul de poule dans
les poulaillers si si si si il fait de
la femme la biche oh non mais il faut
pas de n'y a pas de fantasme de peur de
rien
mais regardez le sucre en poudre oui on
pourrait dire il y aura plus de
betteraves dans les champs massy c'est
très important
oui enfin je préfère garder entre la
betterave et la poule à la pousse très
joli ah bon je peux pas vous en a pas
les poules non non enfin puis ça pue on
est revenu on n'est pas tous dans les
champs dans les airs il ya des gens qui
vivent en ville
moi j'ai pas de poule dans mon jardin je
viens moi j'aime bien chez les autres
ah oui loin et là c'est ça que je
propose c'est à dire c'est que à la
ferme il est tout ce que vous voulez
parce que c'est quand même génial un
champ vous avez un champ vous avez de la
terre vous avez le soleil le vent la
pluie et crac ya des trucs qui poussent
mais pourquoi transporter des choses qui
s'abîme jusqu'à paris il ya des voiliers
un camion de tomates ses neuf tonnes et
2002 quand le vent l'eau à l'ap à la
ferme
il y en aura une poudre comme ça tu
transportes qui se stockent et dia pas
besoin il n'a pas besoin de frigo
impérissable oui oui j'ai gelé depuis
longtemps je m'en sers genre feu jean
louis je vous dis un quart de cuir est
pour une sauce de dix personnes avaient
regardé et du coup le produits valorisés
pour l'agriculteur bien sûr le marist
ancien ministre argentin de
l'agriculture quand il m'a fait venir
dans son ministère
il joue expliqué ça il m'a dit je vous
donne de l'argent immédiatement parce
que ça va régulariser les cours et ce
qui est le pire pour les agriculteurs
c'est les cours qui plus est donc là là
on a un moyen signate d'enrichir les
agriculteurs robin aux importants n'ont
donc ça c'est le projet d'accord ok
après on va passer à vos oeuvres parce
que vous n'êtes pas que chercheurs
souhaitent aussi écrivain vous avez
plusieurs noms ça vous ferait pas
écrivez moi je passais flaubert
je délivre un chercheur il écrit toute
la journée
vous écrivez pour le grand public va
vous paraître lui acheta une dizaine la
lecture du premier livre d'ailleurs ça
serait sympa
einstein disait si vous pouvez pas
expliquer à un enfant dans le premier
que je préfère si vous préférez ah oui
oui de loi ouais mais c'est ça notre
côté littérature va en fait moi ce
que je voulais parce que c'est le
premier c'était la cuisine dans ma
casseroles les secrets de la casserole
voilà bon ça c'est un best seller 1992
dont vous avez démarré en 4,9 secondes
aujourd'hui on en compte 92 doc 6 8 6 et
13 juin il a été remanié puisque avait
des tout petits changements donc à me
donner des recettes et non non non pas
dans ceux de jean suit d'assez c'était
les questions par exemple est il vrai
que vous pouvez rattraper une béarnaise
qui a tourné avec une purée de froide
d'accord voilà
est il vrai que
chez poc les fausses idées qu'on peut
avoir ou les vrais voulez vous les vrais
parfois parce que pour la cuire et l'eau
dans la baie renaissent c'est vrai c'est
bien incroyable ça c'est vous prenez
bernès vous faites exprès de la faire
tourner vous mettez une cuillerée d'eau
et craque elle reprend miraculeusement
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on a fait
un séminaire le dessus construire à
cuire et donal byrne
après il ya eu bon il ya eu 17 livres
total look vois pas tous les pc en vue
mais si on pouvait incarner la
couverture d'un autre livre qui
s'appelle mon histoire de cuisine sud à
moi j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il
devrait remplacer le tout premier parce
que celui-là il est cohérent il est
complet il il ya les aspects historiques
géographiques biologique chimique à tous
dedans
et quand ils montrent une évolution de
la cuisine celui-là et des prix plus
intéressants
ouais je trouve très bien donc on va
envahir celui-là effet d'abaisser le
dernier c'est bientôt si ce dernier se
permettait donc on va voilà le terroir à
toutes les sauces alors celui-là je
trouve différents des autres est très
différent parce qu'il a un côté romand
il ya une histoire
à l'intérieur on apprend que vous êtes
d'origine alsacienne vous ne dormez
c'est pas moi dedans c'est pas vous bien
sûr que non on n'apprend rien du tout
n'aurait dû tourner à produire non on
apprend des tas de recettes alsacienne
du cru arrivé ça oui mais ça va c'est
vrai mais vous savez produire un brochet
beurre blanc oui on enfin alsace paix on
en fait on en fait au pays nantais on en
fait en normandie victoire finale et
parce que je veux montrer c'est que
d'abord cette question de terroir et
c'est une question compliquée parce que
c'est ce qui est ce qu'il existe
vraiment terroir ce pays moi j'ai un
copain qui est le jour d'hui le patron
du centre inra de clermont ferrand dakar
ce gars là il a étudié le reblochon et
la montre et il a démontré que l'europe
le chant de montagne et de plaies n'est
pas le même
maintenant il a même démontré que entre
le versant nord est le versant sud une
petite montagne auvergnat c'est pas le
même fromage ces camions et donc oui
c'est explosif
exactement alors ça c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai et puis il ya des des appellations
de protection de territoire attendez
c'est un vrai terroir mais votre
beauchamp qui est de du nord ou du sud
la de la même montagne c'est quoi son
terroir parce qu'il ya deux terroirs en
vrai mairie alors du coup on dit il vous
imaginez vous dites terroir yvelines
yvelinois où il dînait chez votre monde
dit ça serait presque fini les cours il
nous reste dans la prédiction des
retraités de la joie de vivre chance
elle a traité la jabra ce trésor qu'un
cuisiner ces trois choses selon vous
alors on y va de la langue de l'amour
d'abord un premier camp cuisine
quelqu'un ça veut dire je t'aime qu'on
cuisine quelqu'un de faire parler aux
quelque 1,8 je t'aime sais où je te
donne un plat ça veut dire que je t'aime
très bien et inversement tu me fais
confiance qu'il n'est pas emprisonné qui
peut le manger en confiance en cette
relation là elle est très essentielle et
vitale essentielle très bien après
cuisiner c'est aussi dollars mais pour
certains pierre gagnaire est un grand
travail et beaucoup
ouais c'est pas je travaille pas avec ma
muse mais pierre est un grand artiste il
ya quelques artistes faire bon ça veut
dire faire beau à manger donc c'est une
question artistique quelque chose de
laid sent mauvais non je diffère bon on
sait quelque chose de de faire bon c'est
quelque chose de beau à manger ajoute la
beauté cuit twinair c'est le beau
d'accord ok ça peut être l'est du moment
que ces boues et si c'est bon c'est bon
bon
et troisièmement technique vous êtes le
plus fier alors moi c'était très est à
dire les cuisines sont pas très bons
techniciens par rapport à moi moi je
peux faire j'ai fait 48 de blancs en
neige avec un seul blanc d'oeuf donc je
meilleurs techniciens qu'un cuisine
certes
donc il faut pas que l'aiguillé se pas
se pose en technicien qu'il faut qu'ils
se posent en artiste bon et pourquoi
faut-il y voir si elle est là parce que
c'est un traité de la joie de vivre
chemin et c'est très important
d'apprendre à être heureux pour soi mais
aussi pour les autres parce que si je
tire la tronche comme ça ses portes de
prison s'il y faire grand sourire
alary c'est important il faut faux bon
moi j'ai le droit de dire que j'ai adoré
ses recettes ou pas merci tout fait
ben j'ai fait une tentative mais j'ai
fait dans ma tête et du sens la salade
de pommes de terre on a l'impression que
c'est là la vraie recette c'est la vraie
recette alors s'entraîner parce que moi
je suis pas habilité à donner des
recettes fiscales artistes en revanche
non mais même même l'alsace
en revanche je suis habilité à donner
des recettes juste c'est-à-dire ski mais
ce qui m'énerve c'est un gars qui
écrivait des livres de cuisine baron
britich tout était faux alors là la
trieuse jouer ça marche parce que il
faut que ça justement hervé this ragots
merci d'être venu jusqu'aux yeux nous
tous vos travaux y perd complètement
génialement passionnant je recommande la
lecture de le terroir à toutes les deux
et des autres ouvrages
merci et j'espère a très vite la cuisine
de la note avait là très important les
risques d'actes voilà une actu à bientôt
[Musique]